CBS News has learned former president Donald
Trump's legal team has turned over additional
classified material which was discovered last
month at his Mar-A-Lago home this development
comes as FBI agents find another classified
document during a planned search of former
vice president Mike Pence's Indiana home Pence
who is mulling over his own presidential bid
may have to testify against his former boss
he's been subpoenaed by the justice department
special counsel investigating Trump's alleged
effort to overturn the 2020 election results
Robert Costa has more on this local police blocked
the driveway leading to the Penn's family home as
FBI officials conducted an exhaustive five-hour
search leaving with one document with classified
markings and six additional Pages Pence and his
family were traveling in California his team
fully cooperated with the search which came
weeks after around 12 classified documents
were found in the residence last month the
former vice president who is considering a
2024 presidential bid told CBS in early January
he took no classified documents when leaving
office there were no classified materials that
that left the White House or remained in our
possession but Days Later a personal aide did
find documents in his home mistakes were made
and I take full responsibility for pens it's just
the latest interaction with the justice department
special counsel Jack Smith investigating former
president Trump's efforts to overturn the election
wants to hear from Pence under oath about the
pressure campaign he faced from Trump and I
hope Mike is going to do the right thing I hope
so Trump's Relentless pleas for Pence to block
the certification of the election and his refusal
to do so spark Fury among some Trump supporters
on January 6. [Music] the president's words and
actions in and around January 6 were Reckless
of interest to the special counsel sources
said his Pence has reportedly intense meeting
with Trump in the Oval Office on the eve of the
capital attack when Trump was trying to cling
to power but it's unclear how exactly Pence
will handle the special counsel subpoena and
whether Trump will try to block Pence's potential
testimony by citing executive privilege when it
comes to private discussions and it's worth
noting that Pence's top eight have already
both cooperated with the Justice Department's
investigation into January 6. and sources tell
us Pence's team is now waiting to see whether
former president Trump will try to block the
former vice president from doing the same for
CBS Saturday morning Robert Costa Washington